[MUSIC PLAYING]
DEEP KAPADIA: Hello.
Hello.
Thank you for coming, everyone.
My name is Deep Kapadia.
I am the executive director
for Delivery Engineering
at the "New York Times."
I'm here with my
colleague, Prashanth.
PRASHANTH SANAGAVARAPU: Hey.
DEEP KAPADIA: We're here to tell
you a story about the "New York
Times."
We decided to move to the
cloud a couple of years ago,
and we went through a
really interesting journey.
And if you're thinking about
what the "New York Times" is
doing in the cloud, we're,
traditionally, a newspaper,
but today we do
a lot more things
besides publishing a newspaper.
And I wanted to show you
a one-minute clip of some
of the things that we do on an
ongoing basis, and let her rip.
If In can find the mouse first.
There, we go.
Perfect.
[VIDEO PLAYBACK]
[TELEPHONE RINGING]
- Hey.
- Sorry, so I got the
folks here at Kinkos
to let me use the phone.
[MUSIC PLAYING]
- That's it for "The Daily."
I'm Michael Barbaro.
See you tomorrow.
[END PLAYBACK]
DEEP KAPADIA: OK, sorry.
So-- sorry again.
Transitions are a problem.
So you saw a lot of
things in that video,
and I think what
stands out is the fact
that the way we produce and
showcase journalism today
is very different from
what we used to do, like,
maybe 20 years ago.
So there's a lot of products
that you saw or a lot of things
that you saw in
the clip, and it is
important to know
that we've transformed
from being a newspaper to
being a full-fledged media
company, which requires a lot
of technology and engineering
problems to actually
continue running.
And we continue to
experiment with newer
ways of telling stories.
Like you saw Snapchat,
Discover, augmented reality,
a lot of those things require
a lot of engineering manpower
to run but also
a lot of compute,
a lot of understanding
of how to serve
the content at large scale.
So I want to talk to you
about what it means to do that
and why did we go down the path
of moving to the Google Cloud.
What did our plan look like?
How did we go through some
process and culture shifts,
some of the lessons learned.
And also a little bit about
what we are working on today.
So this is where we started.
So if you were to look
at the image here,
this was our first ever
home page in November 1996.
And if you can read the
line at the bottom it says,
"please open your
window to the width
of the line of this text."
So clearly, not a
responsive design.
It was mostly a GIF
with an image map,
where you could click
through into stories,
and we've come a
long way from that,
as you saw in the video clip.
Today, the website, nytimes.com,
the main web site, runs on GKE.
It's a managed Kubernetes
platform by Google.
There have been a lot of talks,
including the keynote about it.
We embraced a lot
of Cloud-native ways
of deploying and building stuff
that allowed us to move faster.
And we shut down our data
centers this year in April,
so we don't have co-located
data centers where
we run our website out of.
And this is what it
looks like today.
The home page, you
don't need to open it
to the width of the
line of some text.
We are responsive.
It will resize.
But the homepage is a fairly
complex mishmash of content.
And also, we have our article
pages, our interactive,
and graphics.
That one, we did for
the 2016 election.
So for special events, we do
special apps to tell stories
in a specific way.
There's newer products that
we've built along the way,
like our cooking app.
We've always had
recipes in the newspaper
that we brought together,
and like, you know,
built a cooking app,
where people can share,
annotate recipes,
and things like that.
The crosswords app
has a life of its own.
It is our highest
grossing product,
and it's a very
popular one as well.
So all the things
that I'm talking about
require a lot of things
behind the scenes.
We're talking about APIs.
We're talking about APIs that
manage our content, our content
management systems that the
newsroom uses to actually write
and build these experiences,
the consumer revenue
side of things, where
we manage subscriptions
and make sure that we are
also reporting on those.
Our archives are a great source
of research for institutions,
and students, and professors,
and researchers alike,
and then lastly, our mobile
platforms, our mobile apps.
The way people consume
content is changing,
so mobile apps are
a ubiquity for us.
But there were a
lot of challenges
to get from where we
were to where we are.
As of two years ago, the
challenges listed here
are pretty much the
challenges that a lot
of technology organizations face
as the landscape is shifting.
The "New York Times"
had a website in 1996.
Surprisingly, it's been
in existence online longer
than Google has been.
So we had an IT team that
was actually just managing
that website, which
was a very simple GIF
that someone would
upload and an image
map that people
could click through
into a larger infrastructure
team, many, many product teams.
Organic growth sprouted lots
of products and platforms.
Everyone was doing things
a little bit differently,
sometimes significantly
differently,
and that's difficult to scale.
Especially, when people start
doing things differently,
it becomes very hard very
quickly to move faster.
Like, you tend to build silos,
and you tend to work in silos.
And any time you have
to work across silos,
it becomes very, very
hard for you to move.
As a result, a lot
of these-- a lot
of the apps that we
were trying to push out
were basically a spaghetti or
a mishmash of architectures
that people put together to work
around some of the constraints,
because the IT infrastructure
team was very small,
and it couldn't scale very fast.
And the big problem
we had is that we
had to move very, very fast.
I mean, we wanted to move at
the speed at which Google,
Facebook, and our
other competitors
are able to move
at today, and that
was becoming harder and harder.
So we decided-- and we talked
long and hard about this,
so what we decided
to do was form
a team that would
evangelize best practices
and also build common
tooling for engineers,
kind of like what Google does
for all their other clients.
But we decided very early
on that this was not
a team that would run your
infrastructure for you,
so if you were a
web app-- like, you
couldn't lob a web app over the
wall to an infrastructure team
and say, oh please, run
it and scale it for us.
We would ask teams to do that,
but we would provide the teams
with the support and the
tools needed to do that.
And we would help teams build
the operational maturity
along the way, and we would
manage some common tooling
along the way.
So like everyone needs to
build and deploy applications--
everyone was talking about
continuous integration,
continuous deployment--
you need something to do that.
You need something
to manage secrets.
You need a common way
for you to build stuff.
You also need to build
maturity as a part of your site
reliability
engineering practice.
So we would work with teams
to help them understand
SRE practices, build tooling,
monitoring, et cetera, and also
a lot of test automation
which means building
tools for testing and
integrating those tools
with your CI/CD pipeline.
So that was sort of the mandate
around which this team was
formed and evolving over the
course of the last two years,
and I will let Prashanth
talk about how we actually
implemented some of the
changes that I just mentioned.
PRASHANTH SANAGAVARAPU:
Thanks, Deep.
So as Deep mentioned, there
were challenges we were seeing,
and we founded
Delivery Engineering
to solve that problem.
Now I'm going to talk
about how we saw migration
as an opportunity to
solve those challenges.
And I'll walk you
through what services
we chose from Google
and the strategy
that we implemented
for Cloud migration.
And also, we'll look
at our migration plans.
Sorry, it took a while
for that to pick up.
So what we want are
the things that we
saw from our challenges,
and what we chose
is what I'm going
to talk in detail.
What we needed was a highly
scalable and reliable
infrastructure.
Our scaling needs
are spiky at times.
When we send out a
breaking news alert,
we have to scale up pretty
quick to serve that traffic,
and it could be like
an event-based scale-up
where the scaling needs were,
like, based off events too.
Like, if we were to--
if we are hosting an
event like elections,
or Olympics, maybe
any special event,
we had to scale up
our infrastructure.
For that, what we
needed is to build
apps that could rely on reliable
infrastructure like GCS,
BigQuery, Bigtable, and GKE.
They all have published
SLAs, and they
have pretty much reliable.
So we chose to work
with these services that
are managed by Google.
And Deep mentioned that
we wanted to be fast.
The way we wanted to be
fast is by bringing autonomy
in managing environments
for developers.
Over the years of
experience, what we found
is developers are more
knowledgeable about managing
their application
in case of an outage
or shipping that huge
configuration change that
could make a lot of impact.
So what we chose was to
use GCP projects as a tool
to provide that autonomy
and give developers
the full access to
their own environments
and help them manage their own
infrastructures in production.
At the time when we were
in our data centers,
we saw how containers could
help maybe for scaling or maybe
for making the parity between
your dev stage environments.
And we wanted to adopt
container technology
as a main-scale way
of deploying, building
and deploying applications
to production.
At the time, we evaluated with--
we were evaluating container
orchestration services
like Marathon Mesos,
Nomad, and Kubernetes.
In the end, as a
company, we decided
to adopt Kubernetes as our
container orchestration
service.
But if we were to
build and manage
Kubernetes infrastructure
for the entire company, then
a developer engineering team,
is a small team in number,
we'd have been dealing
with just managing
the nodes and clusters, and
patching them, and whatnot.
So when Google came out with
managed Kubernetes service,
which is GKE, it was
quite easy for us
to double down on GCP and
GKE and rely on Google
to manage our
infrastructure, that is,
the Kubernetes infrastructure.
So what we were looking at was
a true engineering partner,
who could provide
services and support
for building applications
as well as even run
those applications for us.
So that's how we chose
our GKE services, what
we wanted to work with,
but we had to build up
a strategy for migration.
The way we we saw our
strategy was to build--
it's not just like
lift and shift
but lean onto the shift more,
meaning shift the processes
that we were working with--
that is our culture--
and the tooling that
supports this migration.
So we wanted to shift
the processes, culture,
and tooling.
So shift in processes,
as I mentioned,
we gave GCP projects as a way
to provide development autonomy
in managing their
own infrastructure.
What that really
meant was teams would
know what they own
in their GCP projects
and their destiny of
those services too.
We moved away from this culture
of having an ops team that
would manage their applications
in production to developers
owning their
services end to end,
so that's a culture
shift that we did.
And traditionally, we were
working off a ticket-based
system, and we wanted to change
that by building automation
that are common across multiple
teams and projects by just
using off-the-shelf tools
like GCloud and [? kubectl, ?]
or [? kube-control, ?] whatever.
And we wrote documentation--
we built a lot of centralized
documentation and step-by-step
guides to onboard
teams to the automation
that Developer Engineering
built and helping them
manage their infrastructure.
So we basically moved away
from ticket-based traditional
infrastructure way
of handling tasks
that are common between
application deployments
to much more self-service model
of building automation that
solved these common tasks.
So as we were
migrating, we also saw
that we were going
into a different land
altogether from a
data center to GCP.
Not every team was aware
of how Kubernetes worked
or what GCP services could do.
So we had to build
a lot of training.
We engaged with Google and
educated a lot of teams
around how Kubernetes GKE could
be employed to build and apply
their applications and so on.
So what we did here is built
those transferable skills.
The culture shift is yes,
there is projects there.
There are applications
that are building,
but we needed to build
that consistency in the way
how these teams could work
with those environments.
The way how we did that
with that was with training.
We built those transferable
skills on teams,
so if an engineer were to move
from one team to another team,
they would be comfortable in
understanding that environment.
The culture shift in the way how
we managed our CI/CD processes.
So I gave a little bit of
an insight into everybody
gets a project, and
they're off their own,
and they can configure
whatever they want.
But the way how we wanted
to bring consistency
in managing these environments
is by building automation
around CI/CD.
So we adopted Drone, a
container-based deployment
tool, to help
deploy applications.
The shift that came out of
is we were not setting up
build bots the a config
management tool with Jenkins,
and teams don't have
to go back and forth.
All we have is just a YAML
file, where their pipeline is
described as code, and we, as
the Delivery Engineering team,
provided that YAML
file as a template.
So teams could extend that
template and deploy their app.
So we made a shift from writing
configuration management
code for building app,
building build bots,
and completely on container
technology with Drone.
So Drone and GitHub
are integrated,
and if there is a
good push, then Drone
kicks in and deploys
to wherever it has to.
Secrets, it's a big topic.
When we are in our
data center, there
are various ways teams use
to manage their secrets.
It could be [? Gitlab, ?] or
it could be Puppet Hiera YAML.
So there were various ways,
and obviously that, too,
[INAUDIBLE].
We wanted to tackle
that by deploying Vault,
HashiCorp Vault. Vault
is a single tool that
had been integrated into
our GitHub and Drone,
so every team gets a secret
backend space for Vault. We
call it namespace, and teams
can write their secrets,
depending on their repositories
and push those secrets
into their namespace without
having to model with other team
secrets.
So with Vault, today we have
about like 75 namespaces,
and the way we
integrate it is if teams
have to build and
deploy new environments,
Vault can completely take
care of these secrets
and deploy to
those environments.
So we've adapted Vault, and
the policies of managing Vault
is also put into Git.
So we use policy management
as code with Vault now.
When we were in
our data center, we
used to have a physical
networking routing equipment
like NetScalers, and also we
had a monolith layer where we
used to create pull requests.
And it was becoming
like a huge monolith
that was taking
our routing layer
into an unmanageable
state, so what
we did is we adapted Fastly.
We made that routing layer
into much more modularized
components that teams
can own and manage
their own routing routes in
terms of writing a VCL code.
So we moved away from
this ticket-based model
of changing routing
paths to modularizing
and making it a code way of
handling the routing logic.
Adopting Fastly,
we also achieved
I would say, in a much
more important feature
is, what we did during the
migration is we wrote logic
to split the traffic
to applications in GCP
by a percentage basis like,
say, 5% of the traffic would
go to GCP applications,
understand how that traffic
pattern would affect
that application,
and learn about these
services in GCP, and move on
and cut over to
maybe 50% or 70%,
and test out how the app
behaved with the modifications
that we were making to fit GCP.
And gradually, we cut
over from our data center
to GCP with Fastly.
Costs-- when we move from
a data center to Cloud,
cost is an important thing.
For us, all of our operational
costs in the data center
were budgeted in
a single budget,
so teams really
didn't know or had
to look into the operational
costs of each application.
But when we gave
GCP projects, teams
had to have visibility into
how much resources that they're
using in the cloud, what we did
is Delivery Engineering, built
a budget bot that basically
alerts teams about the budgets
that they'll set
for the projects.
So people can set
budgets in a YAML file.
As you can see here,
they're setting alerts
for 10%, 20%, or 50%, or 75%.
So the bot basically
sends a slack notification
when the GCP project hit
those budget thresholds,
so we just fortified our
made budgets into code.
Overall, our shift in the way
how we use tooling and culture
now looks like this.
Most of our work is the adopt
space, GitHub based, your code,
pipeline as code,
and infrastructure
as code with GKE and GAE.
And also, managing your secrets
and managing your policies
for secrets is also--
now infrastructure as code
is tied into that notion.
So basically, if
you're a developer,
all you do is get
[? comment, ?] push,
and Drone does [? Kube ?]
Apply onto the GCP projects
and pushes code into
the environments,
so it's much more simpler and
consistent across the projects.
So now I talked
about the services
we chose, the strategy
we used in the way of how
we shifted our data center
applications into GCP.
Now I'm going to talk about
how we executed our migration.
So when we were strategizing and
developing tools around a year
and a half ago, the
"New York Times"
decided to shut down our
data centers by Q1 of 2018.
And we didn't extend
our leases, so we
had to meet those deadlines.
That's the situation we were.
Basically, our planning was
on four major components
that I will hit, which is
networking, data, application,
and monitoring needs
that you are seeing.
So those are the four pillars
that I will cover as migration
and transition plans.
So coming from a
data center mindset,
you all would have
had this experience.
Most of your apps need
physical network in a way
how they connect
with each other.
But as I mentioned, we
were going into a plane
where all applications are
going to be in individual GCP
projects, and we started trying
out fewer networking models
to solve for the connectivity.
The main connections
that we needed
were our data center
to GCP project
by a GCP project in a
hub-and-spoke model,
where there would be
a direct connection
from a centralized
hub project where
we would host our
infrastructure services like DNS
and expand that with VPN
tunnels to other GCP projects.
We experimented
with that, and then
we quickly realized that there
are limitations on how many VPN
tunnels that you could connect
with on a single GCP project,
and we couldn't move forward
with the hub and spoke model.
And then we started looking
into VPN mesh networking
to connect all the GCP
projects with each other
whenever there is a connection
that's needed with VPN tunnels.
Even that didn't scale well,
because it was becoming
a lot of overhead for our team
to maintain these connections
and make sure the VPN tunnels
are healthy and whatnot.
So finally, we met with Google.
We went through our needs.
What we needed was a way
to have our data center
services exposed to
the services that
are getting deployed
in GCP, so we achieved
that using the Cloud Endpoints.
How many of you are
aware of Cloud Endpoints?
Have you experimented
with Cloud Endpoints?
That's quite a few.
Cloud Endpoints is a proxy
that is built by Google.
I would highly recommend--
there are not many people that
raised their hands.
I'm aware of the
Cloud Endpoints--
I'll raise mine-- but
one thing I would say
is this proved to be a
solution that we could use.
I would highly recommend looking
at the way Cloud Endpoints can
be deployed, but it's a
container, NGINX container,
that Google provides.
And it has authentication.
It can help you
provide authentication
against your services that
don't have auth right now.
So we use Cloud Endpoints
to deploy our GCP projects
to have connection between--
prior to project on
a zero trust network.
And that is Google's way.
Google's prescribed way is
to implement TLS encryption
everywhere and beyond
Zero Trust Network.
We also deployed the
same Cloud Endpoints.
Google cal;s it as
extended service proxy.
We deployed that extended
service proxy in our data
centers to expose the services
that are in our data centers
to the project and services that
are in multiple GCP projects.
So that's how our network had
transformed from a physical VPN
network to a zero trust TLS
encrypted-based network.
And also, we started
moving away from firewalls.
We rely on IAM roles to limit
access between services.
Data-- not all of our
migrations were dump and load.
What we did is we
started syncing data
to GCS bucket and migrate
our data to services that
are managed by Google like
BigQuery, Bigtable, Datastore,
Cloud SQL, and Spanner.
It required a little
bit of rewriting,
but we first migrated
our data, syncing them
into these abstractions, and
we started cutting over slowly.
So not all were dump and
load, but some of them were.
So I mentioned our strategy was
to use GKE/GAE services that
are managed by Google.
And our planning, we made
sure that most of our apps
have migrated to
those abstractions,
then going into a
VM-based model where
teams have to manage their VMs.
This particularly helped
us in the migration,
because teams were just
focusing on the features,
and Google was managing their
infrastructure for them.
So the transition was
much faster for us.
And what it did was, by
providing that consistent
automation that Drone gave,
we converted all of our apps
to fit into GKE/GAE model and
[? 12-factorizing ?] them.
Like I said, we
standardized our pipelines,
and we used Google Deployment
Manager and Terraform to set up
the basic infrastructure
that is needed
before the deployments began.
How many of you here are
working with more than one
monitoring logging tools here?
Wow, That's nice.
Cool.
Usually, teams often ask for
that specific monitoring tool
that they like.
In the "New York
Times" we ended up
having a slew of monitoring
and log-in tools.
As part of our migration, we
wanted to reduce that number.
What we didn't have is a default
or a standard way of setting
monitoring reports or
dashboards for alerts,
so what we started doing is
to rely on Google Stackdriver
for setting up that
basic monitoring
and alerting that
we had to provide.
Today, we have slack
on [? page review ?]
integrations with Stackdriver,
and every application
has a basic dashboard
that we could--
any team member could go and
look at and understand their
[? SLIs. ?]
So I talked about a lot
of strategy execution.
That's all great,
but what we noticed
is teams are at various levels
of operational maturity.
So we had to up our
game over there,
and I'll hand it
over to Deep to talk
about operational maturity.
DEEP KAPADIA: Is
something wrong with this?
So yeah, like
Prashanth talked about,
like the process of
the migration itself,
but a great part of this was
building operational maturity
into our practices and on
the teams that were actually
going to build and maintain
these applications.
So we realized very early on,
as Prashanth mentioned, not
all development teams are at
the same level of maturity.
Like, we had teams
that were absolutely
thrilled at the prospect
of being in the cloud,
and having all the autonomy,
and wanting to build everything
from scratch versus
teams that just wanted
to build their
little Node.js app
and just, like, have it
deployed somewhere in the cloud
or just write
application features
but not really worry
about operations.
So I think we had to level
set very early on with a lot
of these teams, and we realized
that during the migrations
a lot of these teams
need a lot of support.
So Prashanth mentioned
all the trainings
that we did, all the
documentation that we wrote,
like, setting up the
right level of support
was very, very important.
And one of the biggest things
we talked about with teams
was being on call, like making
sure that we are giving teams
a lot of autonomy to run their
infrastructure in the cloud,
but at the same time it
comes with some level
of responsibility.
The level of responsibility
is around managing costs,
also managing their uptime
and their SLIs and SLOs
on an ongoing basis.
There was not going to be
a central infrastructure
team or a centralized
system team going forward
to actually manage the
uptime for their apps
and also be on call
for those apps.
So one of the things we did was,
every time someone wanted to--
someone decided that they were
going to move to the cloud,
and they came up with a
plan, we would kick that
off with application
readiness reviews just
to assess where the
team and the application
are from a maturity standpoint.
It was very important
for us to do.
So we started doing
it with certain teams,
and then other teams just
jumped on it and said,
oh, well, we also want
to move to the cloud.
Can you help us
assess where we are,
and what we need to work on?
And like, the ideal
was to identify
gaps, not just from a
technical standpoint but also
for us to understand,
for our team
to understand where we will
need to provide support,
and how much support
will these teams need.
We also instituted
regular office hours,
where people could come
and talk to us about rando.
Questions, but at the same time
what the office hours did was
it served as a community
building exercise of sorts.
Like, people from
multiple teams would
show up and talk
about their issues,
and then find solutions
to each others problems
as a part of it,
which was excellent
because that sort of took
us out of the picture,
and the teams are actually
talking to each other
and also--
sort of put our
engineers in front
of the Google technical
account managers and,
like, the Google
customer engineers that
were embedded with us for
the course of the migration
was really, really helpful.
Thank you, Jim, [? Romey, ?]
[? Asher, ?] very much.
And of course, you
know, they were there--
it was a shared fate for both
of us, as well as Google.
So they were there to support
us doing our major launches,
during our major
migrations, et cetera.
And just before you
decide to switch over
to production in the cloud,
let's do a production
assessment and make sure
that you have all the things
that you need, to make sure that
you are ready for a calamity
or in case you have to fall back
to the data center for a while
what the plan for that is.
So just doing a production
readiness review
was very important.
We read this book, right?
Like, this is where most
of our ideas came from.
I wish we had written
that book, but we didn't.
But yeah, the idea was
evangelize reliability
as a feature.
To us, it was very important
that people understand
that all the features that
you build into your product
are great, but at the
same time, if you do not
prioritize reliability of
your apps as a feature,
it can all go to
waste very quickly.
Like, it only takes
four spinning wheels
on an app for me to
uninstall that app,
and I'm guessing a
lot of other people
are maybe as impatient as I
am or maybe a lot less patient
than I am.
So to me it's very important
that reliability is considered
a feature, so it's not
something of an afterthought
that you would think about.
And that was a big
cultural shift,
where teams started
thinking about building
more and more reliability
into their apps,
monitoring their SLIs, and
tracking their SLOs, et cetera,
and sharing them
across the board.
If a team knew that
there was a dependency
for many other teams,
it was very important
for them to build their SLOs
and share it with other teams.
That's something that we
did through the course
of the migration.
We worked with Google's Customer
Reliability Engineering team.
Nick is here.
Thank you so much
for all your help.
They came and trained
some of our teams.
They also provided us with
a template of assessments
that we work with teams
on and say, like, do you
have some of the
things that you need
to think about
when you are trying
to build more reliability
into your applications,
and allows us to have
the kind of conversations
that the CRE team with us
very early on in the process.
And then, of course, as
a part of the assessment,
you can score high or
low on certain aspects
of your reliability matrix.
And we make sure that
the work that you
need to do to build
more reliability
on your applications are
tracked on an ongoing basis,
so that it doesn't get lost.
This is all work that comes
together, and when it comes
together it's really nice.
And I mentioned being on call.
This, to us, was probably
the biggest culture shift.
So on call freaks
people out sometimes.
Like, it used to freak me out.
It doesn't anymore because we
have built a lot of maturity
around on-call.
But the initial nervousness
is very hard to overcome.
And we had to go
have conversations
with a lot of teams and a lot
of engineers, who are very, very
nervous about what
happens if I get called
in the middle of
night, and I don't
know how to fix the problem?
So the idea is to build more
confidence in your processes
so that your engineers,
your developers,
can feel more confident
when being on call.
We asked teams to develop
playbooks, run books, solutions
to common problems that could
be shared across the board,
perform war games like which is
site [? outted ?] simulations
that people can work
through and actually
build more confidence
in their abilities
to support an application
when they are actually
going on call.
And it continues to be an
ongoing conversation with teams
to build more and more
operational maturity.
So some of the lessons learned
through this whole process,
as Prashanth
mentioned, was do not
try to replicate your data
center setups in the cloud.
Sometimes it'll work--
sometimes it won't.
Be very, very aware of what it
means to run in a public cloud
and what are some of the
constraints it comes with it.
Or what are some of the
constraints of your data center
that may not be constraints
in the public cloud?
Our networking
journey was actually
a very, very good learning
example for a lot of people.
We tried our best to work
against the fabric of Google,
and that didn't work out.
It was just not the
way Google wanted us
to build apps, which is fine.
Google is not--
I personally would
tell my team-- like,
Google is not a vendor for us.
They are a partner.
They have done this.
They've actually figured out how
to run applications, services,
and sites at scale.
This is an opportunity
for not just
them to learn from us but us
to learn from Google as well.
So treat them as a
partner, figure out
what are the best practices
for your cloud provider--
in this case, Google--
to actually run your
applications there.
Review your application
architecture,
connectivity, dependencies.
Like, there were times when we
had an app running in Google
as well as our data center with
certain downstream apps using
the Google side of things,
the data center
side, or an app that
didn't have enough
confidence in their GCP setup
still having the data
center as a fallback
and then gradually
increasing the traffic
as they built more
maturity in the Cloud.
So continue to load test.
The assumptions you make when
you are running in your data
center may not hold true when
you're running in the cloud.
You may need more compute.
You may need less compute.
You may need more memory, like
things like that are important,
so continue to benchmark your
applications during the course
of the migration.
In general, it's a
great thing to continue
to benchmark your
apps through course
of [INAUDIBLE] and like
deployments, et cetera.
One of the things
that we did early on
was manage a centralized
launch calendar.
So teams are aware
of their dependencies
and were always aware of
when their dependencies would
be moving to the cloud or
be ready in the cloud.
So they could
actually coordinate
with their dependencies or
like the depending systems
to be able to talk to
their dependent systems.
Again, I talked about
the CRE engagement.
Like, it was invaluable
for us to have access
to Nick and his team,
and it continues
to be invaluable for us.
It's been amazing for us
to interact with them,
learn from them, and bring their
practices back to the teams
that we work with.
In terms of what's next,
we want to continue
educating teams,
educating ourselves
in SRE best practices.
We want to employ
those across the board.
So for that, we want to build
tools, instrument metrics
in a common way, so
that we're always
talking the same language.
We want to build
organization-wide SLO
dashboards so that we are
always aware of what's going on.
Like, observability is important
to us, especially a news
site that relies on
very high uptime.
News cycles are spiky.
News can happen at any time.
We want to make sure that
we are building a lot more
reliability into
our applications,
so we can provide the most
benefit to our readers.
We want to-- I mentioned test
automation very early on.
It's a fairly new
practice that we
are adopting, but at the same--
what we want to do is
make sure that automation
is a first-class citizen in all
CI/CD pipelines that we built,
so provide tooling for us
to embed functional tasks,
end-to-end tests, load tests
within our CI/CD pipelines
so we can run them as a part of
every deployment or on demand.
And while we do this, we want
to celebrate our successes.
So that's one of the
things we're doing here,
is actually talking about
some of our successes.
We've learned a lot from it.
We want everyone else to
learn from it as well.
And if any of this sounds
interesting to you,
please come join us.
We are hiring.
We want to work with
smart people, people
who we can learn from, so
it's always interesting.
We always talk about our
experiences on the open blog
that we publish, so yeah,
that's pretty much it.
OK then, thank you, everyone.
And we are here if you
want to talk to us.
Like, come and talk to us.
Those are the people
from the "New York Times"
over here, over there.
Please come talk to all of us.
Thank you.
[MUSIC PLAYING]